alors nous nous donnons à ce qu'on peut
trouver l'amour à la télé dit plus marie
vous êtes avec nous et marie et selim
vous pensez vous qu'on peut trouver
l'amour qu'on ne peut pas trouver
l'amour arrêté marie vous vous avez été
brisé par la téléralité vous êtes on est
en cours entre le 8 juillet 2011 dans la
maison des secrets c'est secret story
dans ses bras est restée chez lui c'est
vrai qu'il a brisé pas que le ciom en
compagnie de votre petite amie de plus
d'un an de relation s'était geoffrey je
me rappelle très très bien et depuis
c'est celle escalade de l'horreur ah oui
au niveau sentimental c'est mort déjà
parce que vous êtes rentré vous pensiez
vraiment de votre couple allait résister
j'avais pas conscience en fait ouais des
risques que je prenais tout simplement
où il est juste faire de la télé c'est
sa gto dans le monde des bisounours
c'est ça pour moi personne ne les
regarde et je savais pas vraiment ce que
c'était secretstory et j étais les yeux
fermés en ayant entièrement confiance en
mon mec alors on se rappelle de vous
regarder on va regarder il y avait eu 1
s'était pas souvent le bonheur entre
vous deux dans l'émission on a une image
d'une embrouille entre vous et geoffrey
regardez geoffrey n'a pas à se
rapprocher d'autres fier puisqu'il est
censé jouer le jeu avec une en
particulier
voilà
str ap
une fois que je me dis que j'ai eu le
sentiment d'un que moi je fais beaucoup
d'efforts et qu'on me fait une fois
puisque beaucoup de reproches
c'est vrai que je suis très anciens
alors son avis sur geoffrey rare a kiffé
geoffrey alors donc après votre couple a
été détruit
oui mais pourquoi vous n'avez pas
retrouvé l'amour derrière je comprends
pas non non mais vous avez enchaîné les
émissions enchaîné oui oui oui oui j'ai
enchaîné en espérant bien pour mon image
serait redorer et finalement ça n'a pas
du tout été le cas alors vous
déconseiller aux jeunes de trouver
l'amour à la télévision est de faire de
la télé réalité c'est de faire de télé
réalité c'est vraiment vous déconseiller
complet oui complètement
ah ouais pas avoir un très bon mental
parce que on dit on dit que à un moment
vous étiez vraiment on dépression totale
que vous avez vous avez voulu un moment
voilà même mettre fin à votre vie se
confie ce que les journalistes de
l'émission ont dit non non non c'est un
dans l'émission non non non après non
non non en fait je suis après tombé sur
un pervers narcissique donc ça a été
tout à fait différent cette surtaxe de
l'ormeau josé pas voulu dire non et donc
ouais donc après et après vous avez
enchaîné
oui mais c'est peut-être pas de la faute
de la télévision aux braves khelil
non mais c'est vrai mais après disons
que pour rencontrer quelqu'un quelqu'un
de lambda sait jamais s'il est là pour
ce que vous êtes pour la notoriété ou
éventuellement l'argent parce que tout
le monde s'imagine qu'on ait pété dessus
ouais si on rencontre quelqu'un de connu
et ben si c'est un artiste
en général les fans de l'artiste des
conseils à la personne de se mettre avec
une fille téléréalité d'accord qu'il
garde une mauvaise image
c'est ça mais y'a plein de gens bien qui
sont partis ce tu peux rencontrer cannes
car la boulangerie pharmacie à
l'aéroport à la gare des polices du sort
de ces crêtes tu vas dans une autre
émission de télé réalité c'est que tu
cherches aussi nos trucs alors que je
rentre c'est ça c'est ça fait moins huit
heures mais après rencontrer quelqu'un
de bien la boulangerie systématiquement
derrière et à ses potes qui vont arriver
qui vont lui dire mais elle allait
tahrir est précis les coûts de ses potes
c'est que c'est pas un mec pourtant à
l'esm partir ou là excusez moi vous êtes
un conseiller matrimonial
ce mec alors vous majeur à castanet où
vous étiez animateurs du bisou qui s'est
dit là dessus
bad en cas de sacre est allé rentrée
avec un secret qui était compliqué à
garder puisqu'elle devait cacher sa
relation après geoffrey de ce don ce
qu'on a vu de ce que je n'ai pu en voir
et de ce qu'ils étaient dans le
programme n'était pas super
recommandable donc peut-être que
peut-être que l'émission tard on
observer si tu peux tu trouves à la
révéler ce qu'ils pensaient vraiment de
toi mais effectivement je je je suis ce
qu'elle dit penser qu'on va trouver
l'amour à la télévision est maintenant
dans les nouvelles télés à l'été ça me
paraît très peu de vous dites oui la
normale quand on dit oui à l'amour à la
tv on discute pas mais voilà ça l'amour
est dans le pré
oui pourquoi sur bas que pas que mes
notamment dans ça vous gonfle tous quand
je dis le bilan l'impact sur m6 et 50
naissance et quand même scénario on a on
a justement pour vous l'extrait le plus
culte de tous les temps dans l'amour de
l'amour est dans le pré c'est évidemment
l'extrait du bâton voilà où cela dure
du lot et les millions juste pour qu'on
bascule dans l'amour est dans le pré est
ce qu'on est l'extrait voilà qui est
passée là cette semaine qui est
complètement ou face vous avez vu
l'extrait semaine vous allez voir ça et
que benjamin castaldi en fait non
alors on va on va essayer de retrouver
vous nous vous pensez
gilles verdez c'est impossible tout est
truqué alors mais tout est truqué et
notamment dans l'amour est dans le pré
puisqu'on s'aperçoit que dans cette
édition là l'histoire emblématique entre
raul et lætitia c'est bidon comme c'est
scénarisé y compris dans mario premier
regard tout comme c'est scénarisé les
gens ne sont pas naturels donc vous
pouvez pas vous aimez vraiment il peut y
avoir du sexe mais pas de sentiment et
pas d'amour alors je vous lise armand
votre émission préférée de dating ces
ados recherchait c'était diffusé sur ses
beats oui il est 2015 n'a pas fait un
énorme carton
c'était sur une île déserte un homme une
femme se rend compte totalement nue audi
et après il voit ce qu'on regarde et on
a un extrait où ils se sont bien faire
un saut de mouton
j'ai envie de dire curieuse méthode on
amuse on a par exemple
vrai chemin tortueux
[Musique]
oh
c'est lui sont prêtés le gilles verdez
alors vous abonner sabrina vous vous
êtes rencontrés à la télé vous vivez le
parfait amour
vous êtes actuellement candidat dans les
vacances des anges et vous pensez qu'on
peut trouver l'amour à la télé vous
aimez vous avez vraiment parce que je
pense que c'est vrai gilts à peut-être
raison que tu dis mon pas faire
d'exception des généralités
parce que l'amour pour moi tu peux le
rencontrer n'importe où tu peux
rencontrer au travail tu peux le
rencontrer à la télé le rencontrer dans
le métro ou ailleurs je vais dire ce
serait très dommage de généraliser ça et
je pense que ça cause de ça qu'on
diabolise les histoires d'amour à la
télé et que justement elles sont cette
étiquette
voilà de fake et et je trouve ça dommage
parce que nous on en a la preuve
aujourd'hui voilà on s'est rencontré sur
une émission de télé c'est un endroit et
ben voilà peut-être qui nous rapproche
un peu plus parce qu'on partage une
expérience très forte
on vit ensemble h24 je pense que vous
déjà entre vous en travaillant ensemble
vous avez d alors
la longue race noire on peut pas
attraper des maladies
j'entends je veux dire que ça crée des
liens
c'est là métier mais c'est mon amitié
bien ce qu elle était non non mais dans
une télé ça je rappelle que n'est pas
d'ici merci oui non mais ce qu'ils
aiment à dans une télé c'est un petit
peu comme une colonie de vacances fois
chanter des jeunes dont entre 18 et 25
ans ensemble dans un cadre paradisiaque
oublier les caméras oublier tout ça mais
on n'oublie pas les gants mais
l'appareil en voyant des jeux vous nous
regardez nous suivraient nous nous
sommes regardés nous aider je voudrais
un rapprochement chez vous tous mais non
mais des jeunes entre 50 et 70 sur qui
se passera mais là où il devrait une
fois de plus se taire c'est quand son
idole total nabil a rencontré l'amour
thomas dans une télé reste et ça fait
six ans qu'ils sont ensemble
alors à moins qu'eux aussi soient fake
peut-être tu peux nous le dira et
j'adore mari parce que je connais bien
la fée les anges ensuite le oumar sy se
trompe on peut trouver l'amour la
télévision ça peut être sincère après
c'est qu'est ce que tu vas y faire c'est
vrai qu'à cette époque là quand y allais
est un peu hystérique dans les émissions
dans les anges tête un peu hystérique
aussi et je comprends que du coup quand
tu es dans une boulangerie maintenant
les gens voient un petit peu l'hystérie
mais ça n'a rien à voir avec moi aussi
vous dire et et franchement c'est les
réactions que j'ai pour les gens la
seule émission qui est sincère et qui
permet vraiment de trouver l'amour c'est
l'amour est dans le pré est d'ailleurs
bizarrement c'est la seule qui est
encore à l'antenne et we are tonnes en
question parce que elle est authentique
les mecs ne joue pas les agricole et
greenster ne joue pas mais ces villes et
puis quel manque d'humilité c'est pas
les producteurs du des visions qui écrit
des scénarios c'est lui bah oui excuse
moi c'est là où c'est le destin ça vous
tombe dessus sont pas producteurs comme
ça à la csu a le destin il a fait tomber
de la merde
ac s'il vous plaît raymond qu'est-ce que
vous demandera pas de l'idéal twitter tu
as pris l'exemple du métro tu m'enlèves
aura pas de l'idée que si un jour tu
rends compte que quelqu'un dans le métro
ça peut être quand même une histoire
plus costaude que s'il ya quinze
caméraman c'est sur 610 combat ils
avaient tous des pecs tous les tatouages
ces messieurs je peux même pas la faire
l'émission non seulement jalhaytois
cherche à tâtons
c'est vrai que les forages pour entrer à
gaza cette émission ils ont tout et
tatouages et ils ont des noms chemin
non mais sérieux et alors mais c'est
vrai et il s'appelle tous jean royère
marca ils ont tous des tatouages à lille
mais j'aurais sans qu'ils ont tous des
cordes off on dirait qu avant de vous
faire l'émission who is here n'a pas
récupéré par un labo vers l'île de la
tentation rien si les b mais ouais mais
il restera sur le zodiaque c'est vous
c'est nîmes alors vous êtes vous êtes
mister france et vous vous avez fait les
princes de l'amour et du couple parfait
et vous pensez que c'est impossible de
trouver l'amour dans une émission
pourquoi c'est pas que c'est impossible
c'est que il ya sept huit ans pour moi
c'était encore possible une star sincère
aujourd'hui l'ajout aujourd'hui ça a
évolué il ya les réseaux etc
les gens qui viennent faire de la télé
ils connaissent les codes mais il leur
principale motivation c'est de faire de
télé et c'est pas de trouver l'amour et
c'est pour ça que dans des émissions
comme l'amour est dans le pré où c'est
une émission au corps qui rêve pour moi
authentique parce que on a affaire à des
candidats qui sont pas là pour faire de
la télé mais qui sont là pour trouver
l'amour vraiment ces gens qu'on 40 ans
50 ans etc sont dans une démarche
sincère c'est donc le résultat des
jeunes qui veulent juste on va pas se
mentir on va voir ce que vous en pensez
l'amour est il possible à à la télé s'il
vous plaît le sondage
voilà oui à 42% non à 58 pour ça c'est
qu'on ne peut pas trouver l'amour à la
télé oui quelqu'un où il s'était très
vite que si nous filons est humide on a
gagné
merci